usually when someone tunes into a world
champions twitch stream it's to see them
do something crazy to watch and learn as
these digital gods provide a routine
demonstration of why they're the best
- sit back mouth agait and revel in the
glory of some borderline illegal dump
stirring the way these guys plays like
it's like they turned off their head
however when it comes to the one and
only king of siege nobody's really
interested in watching him pull off
insane [ __ ] they don't want to watch him
rule they want to watch him rage since
winning the inaugural Invitational back
in 2017 George King George Casa has
managed to leverage an early retirement
into arguably the most successful
streaming career in siege but the thing
is people don't so much show up to
behold his skill as much as they do his
salt nitrate at least how on earth how
on earth you're in the animation of
climbing a [ __ ] ladder and you're so
laggy that you kill me anyway
what is this go ham so how is it that a
world-class competitor started cashing
in on being the most recognizable rager
in siege and in some bizarre way are his
red faced antics actually good for the
game
suprise [ __ ] okay so before King George
was something of a twitch celebrity he
was a crow player a pretty good one in
fact he was among the first wave of
players to join the North American crow
League and by 2017 had earned a spot on
continuum where he played alongside mr.
I'm oldest [ __ ] and using the umph
himself Canadian why am I so much [ __ ]
better than you
god damn now you probably know George as
this angry irritable curmudgeon who's
usually on the butt end of a joke but
back in the day he was nothing to laugh
at
I'm gonna choose that connector window
King George gonna pop on out go for the
shot that he gets them down because they
heard the repel happening a very good
set of ears on that man y'all gonna be
inside of the bathroom as Panico has
gotten itself into the B office but from
a ball but another kill from King George
George as a player is actually a very
smart player that was like the main
reason we picked him up we felt like he
had a really good understanding of the
game and he like was good at finding
like cheeky things like Val cam spots
like it was a different meadow of the
game at the time we're like you would
abuse stuff like a good outside Val cam
so George had a good mind for the game
of that sense I'd say for sure I
actually loved teaming with Troy because
we're both on the same page where we're
gonna like tear apart every map trying
to come up with new stuff watch all the
other teams vods like be very analytical
about like every single thing in tactic
about every decision we're making and
that's what set us apart from everybody
else and it was thanks in large part to
George and Canadiens theorycrafting that
they were able to raise the hammer at
the first-ever invitational in 2017 they
have the diffuser locked inside the
a-site they know they've got to come for
it tonight we'll push his way in is it
tucked in the corner 10 seconds to go
comes on around loses the fight the
Canadian once ago is hey being alone and
drop down particular your world
champions
[Applause]
from that point on seed really started
to grow and with continuum looking to
adopt a more aggressive play style it
wasn't long before his Royal Highness
found himself sitting on a bench instead
of a throne
George ended up moving on from continuum
to a roster that would eventually become
ro where he continued to put his
competitive drive on display that's
that's not that's not real that's that's
wow he actually loves acted haka
ladies and gentlemen it's happens we do
have a to Shaka being played for the
first round of this consulate map it is
gonna be old King George I mean even
even in that infamy loss he dropped he
drew I think dropped the most flags of
anyone here you can see Redeemer gonna
drop down and be eliminated by the
rat-a-tat-tat comes out old Georgie
getting that to talk a turret kill just
excellent job there by King George but
it was during this period of his career
that George found himself being drawn to
the one thing that even the most
self-respecting of world champions can
resist content creation on top of
producing helpful guides for serious
players George gave his followers pure
entertainments tapti and then hold on
the trigger though
and the chance to see a world-class
player shooting on match making sense
where is he in time George became more
and more committed to his streaming
audience which created conflict with his
professional career and despite his best
efforts to juggle both full-time life
began to throw more gorge than he could
handle
just before the gamescom land finals I
found out that my grandfather who has
had dementia for seven or eight years
now
was gonna be passing away in a few
months and obviously this was like
really really really hard to meet with
someone that was extremely close to my
entire life I mean like even named after
him and stuff like that so definitely
was someone that was like really really
close with and it just like I don't know
it stressed me out a lot and it caused
me like not sleep very well just seeing
him like that like in the hospital and
my grandma I won't get too much ended up
I'm sure most people can understand and
when that happened it was like a
decision I had to make like I'm not
sleeping I'm not playing well in stream
I'm not playing well like in general I
know I was thinking about just taking a
break and I took a break and I was like
I slept eight hours last night like that
was crazy and then I was just like you
know I just I'm not really in the mood
to do this anymore I could make my own
schedule when I stream like live my own
life have more like options and stuff
and I feel like screaming long-term is
probably a better option fully
committing to streaming checked two
boxes for George it offered in the
competitive outlet he enjoyed but it
also gave him the freedom to play
however he wanted and he ran with it I
think I can make it dude okay thank you
for lining up today
before long Georgia's streamed blew up
which wasn't surprising after all he was
a former world champion who still
clearly loved the game that he made his
name it but at some point it became
apparent that there was another reason
why the siege community was showing up
in spades to watch George while away the
hours and ranks I don't know I think
yeah I think some people come for the
gameplays some people come for the
reactions like if I die I always like
pretty much get mad dude
what the [ __ ] another one just [ __ ]
right there why what are you doing now
anyone who's ever played siege knows
that for a very long time it was a hot
[ __ ] mess riddled with game breaking
[ __ ] so when you threw a fun sized
Greek man with titanic rage into that
equation the results could only be pure
unadulterated hilarity are you [ __ ]
kidding me fix your [ __ ] game Ubisoft
my god dude he's funny when he's mad it
like it is realism I can I can tell you
like every part every pro player out
there like they like playing against
George because they like to see his
reaction like it's it's just it's so
funny I like there's even like little
videos were like the people you play
with it's just like a highlight video of
just them tea cane and there's him
screaming hey get away doing I mean he
rages a lot oh I killed myself what what
just happened what just happened the
thing is it didn't even have to be
completely broken for George to start
balding over it it could be anything
from annoying operators
this guy just he'll learn I hate blitz
dude I even my [ __ ] hate this
operator Ubisoft what the [ __ ] is this
operator to the current state of ranks
yesterday spent all [ __ ] day on
Brazilian servers with a hundred and
fifty [ __ ] ping having Brazilians on
a service all [ __ ] game ping [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of me
or just Comcast in general
you Comcast you [ __ ] bunch of
[ __ ] so what is it specifically that
makes it so funny to watch King George
get all hot and bothered well we wanted
the definitive answer so we went out
into the siege community and asked King
George got 10,000 plus hours in this
game this guy shouldn't be getting mad
at anything and he still does as if he's
getting killed by something for the
first time ever oh this [ __ ] nerd
he's on top of the vent
he's rages like a man look it's great I
think it's just a combination of him
getting mad with his voice because he
almost becomes kind of squeaky when it
goes mad like what are you doing
like it's so it's a pioneer it's it's so
hilarious and over the years
George's distinct brand of rage has
become so iconic to the community that
it's even inspired some exceptional
imitation and then when you get mad at
things you have to do this you have to
do two reactions you have to go oh my
god oh my god or you do this yo what is
he doing what is he doing what is he
[ __ ] doing there what is he doing oh
my god man why are you there but here's
the thing George isn't stupid
he's pretty self-aware at some point he
really started to lean into this persona
Salty's funny I mean he's not the first
twitch streamer to kind of right off the
solve trainer I think everyone has those
kinds of realizations it's like when but
something happens and people are like
hey people are enjoying this so you know
you started like when you feel like oh
you have the chance to do that again
you're going to take it obviously now
with that being said George isn't your
typical rage lording little shitstain
while he can be over-the-top George has
always tried to direct his outbursts at
issues with the game one thing I have to
say I'm never like to people that are on
my team
it's normally like about the situation
like when I die I'm like mad I won't if
there's a teammate on my team I'm never
gonna be the same telling them or
talking trash about them I'm gonna give
them calls and do my best to win the
game even if they're doing poorly at the
end of the day it's not your job to be
like ruining someone else's time I'm
sure that if you talk to King George 15
minutes after one of his outbursts he
would probably say that he regrets
acting that way but in the moment it's
so real and every player feels like that
it's just that not every player acts
that way and it's actually refreshing to
watch somebody who just lets it all out
and and displays the way that we all
feel playing the game sometimes and that
authenticity is a major reason for
George's success there isn't a siege
player alive who hasn't at some point
identified with the man on a spiritual
level there are very few siege heads who
spent as much time as George has
soldiering through the trenches of rank
and the result is that he's become a
reliable litmus test for what is and
isn't broken and these are not the
ramblings of some mad court jester these
are the musings of siege royalty and
when the King speaks people listen you
can't accuse him of not knowing the game
if I came out and I made something you
know I have that I'm a pro league caster
cover but then people can turn around of
me like oh well you know you're only
like a Platt in the game you're only in
gold you're only a silver and only a
bronze or only a copper etc whereas with
him his record in the game is
unimpeachable so when you have the skill
to back up your thoughts and that level
of a platform whether the devs are
seeing what he has to say or not it will
eventually trickle down through the
thousands of people that follow him and
watch his content it will be talked
about on reddit it will be talked about
on Twitch and whether it you know
creates this level of groupthink that
eventually reaches back to the devs I
don't know
but somebody with his reach is able to
set a conversation in motion based on
his own thoughts as squeaky and seething
as it is King George actually possesses
one of the most honest entertaining how
high as my forehead and influential
voices in siege and as ridiculous as he
might appear it's important to remember
that George and his outspoken nature
have done a hell of a lot more to help
siege
then to harm also I have to use the
bathroom if that's okay oh cool okay I
just had to add my steam guard back I
take this off yeah I would I would
prefer you not to hear me it's very high
def Sud cup water in my pants yeah I
didn't pee on my pocket I don't think
you know how magic urine just like so it
comes back to me like a magnet what's
going on